pour le gouvernement cette affaire est
déjà classé le point de presse du
ministre de l'éducation n'a duré qu'une
quinzaine de minutes
il n'avait essentiellement qu'une seule
chose à dire nous interdirons
explicitement les fouilles à nu par des
intervenants sera là une pratique
extrême inefficace et humiliante pour
les jeunes a dit le ministre c'est ce
qui est arrivé à l'école neuchâtel à
québec en février dernier alors qu'une
adolescente de 15 ans a dû se dévêtir
complètement derrière un drap pendant
que la direction de l'école fuyait ces
vêtements pensant à tort qu'elle
possédait des stupéfiants sa vie à
l'école est maintenant pénible dit sa
mère ne montrent ce fossé qui met lé les
jeunes dans l'école social ces qui se
pointent du doigt ce fait crier des noms
elle se réjouit de la décision du
gouvernement alors qu'elle intente une
poursuite judiciaire contre la
commission scolaire et l'école neuchâtel
l'école ne l'avait pas contacté avant de
fouiller sa fille il devra verser les
parents et leur chatte les parrains et
non dans le sens contraire
puis on fait pour abus de pouvoir en
fait les associations de parents
souhaitent que les écoles réfèrent les
cas de drogue aux policiers et si ce que
suggère le ministre de l'éducation ainsi
que les policiers sont formés pour faire
sa jambe d'achat aux liaisons un côté
heidsieck a n'empêche le rapport fait
état de l' isolement de plusieurs écoles
aux prises avec la drogue
l'école d'une intervenante est seul dans
sa misère quand tu as une problématique
qui est urgente
ici la vivent parfois souvent que y'en a
pas de policiers éducateurs il y en a
pas de policiers en service qui peut
venir t'aider si misère il ya un homme
lavillenie n'est pas une solution
un preneur première chose et
deuxièmement on va clarifier des
éléments par rapport au cadre de
référence et d'intervention le pouvoir
de fouille à nu n'apparaît nulle part
dans le cadre d'interventions et de
référence
contrairement à ce qu'avait laissé
entendre l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation yves bolduc sa fâcheuse
déclaration a d'ailleurs mené à sa
démission et à ce rapport le
gouvernement
espère maintenant passer à autre chose
ici martin biron radio canada québec